walk us through your injuries Start Head
To Toe go like surgeries and stuff you
said you had 17 stitches in your face or
something like that I I had a lot of
stitches in my face I think it was more
than 17.
um yeah so tore the nostril off oh it
was you know I mean it was hanging off
yeah they could put it back that's all
dangling that's awesome I didn't mean
like you had to put it in your pocket oh
sorry relax dude
[__] don't start Hollywood at me now
um yeah and you know a pretty big gash
in my face I have a scar on my chest
which I think is from a claw when it
took me down not a big scar I don't even
think I got stitches on it what was the
dog's name you remember the dog's name
that he had Clifford
it's where for the big red bloody dog
dude yeah he was big and wreck as a year
blood exactly
um Clifford almost killed you bro
the Honeydew